منذ ان بدات اخبار الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا تتوالى الى المانيا بدات الجليات
التركيه والسوريه بتجميع المساعدات
لارسالها الى المناطق المنكوبه وهذا واحد
من اماكن تجميع هذه المساعدات في منطقه
كريباج وسط برلين في وسط المنطقه التي تعد
معقل الجاليه التركيه في العاصمه
الالمانيه تحول المعهد التركي للموسيقى
الى مركز لجمع وفرز المساعدات التي يتبرع
بها سكان المدينه الى المنكوبين في تركيا
كلنا جئنا الى هنا للمساعده هناك عدد كبير
من الاشخاص ياتون يوميا ويملاون الصناديق
ويشرفون على تجميعها طوال اليوم ومعهد
الموسيقى التركي هنا يتواصل مع السفاره
التركيه والقنصليه التي ستنقل هذه
المساعدات في الشاحنات وتدقق فيها قبل ان
ترسلها الى تركيا على متن طائره تابعه
للخطوط الجويه التركيه
وفيما تجمع الجاليه التركيه في المانيا
نفسها لتقديم ما امكن من المساعدات
استنفرت الجاليه السوريه هناك ذلك وفتحت
الكثير من المراكز الثقافيه والاجتماعيه
ابوابها لجمع التبرعات وارسالها الى سوريا
مثل جمعيه سلام رغم ان المهمه هنا اصعب
بكثير وارساله هذه المساعدات ما زال غير
مضمون نحن عملنا
هذا التجميع للمساعدات لنقل الشمال السوري
وجنوب تركيا حيث اللاجئين والمناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال راح نجتمع راحن مع
جمعيات صديقه تركيه مؤسسات ومؤسسات دوليه
نسق معه بحيث المواد هاي اتصال باسرع وقت
ممكن للناس المتضررين وفي تضارب كثير في
المعلومات بصراحه ما في معلومات دقيقه ولا
نحن على التواصل مع شركائنا في الداخل او
الحدود واي معلومه تصل بتفتح المعابر اكيد
الاغراض الموجوده هون في المانيا ما راح
تصل خلال 24 ساعه على سوريا ولكن نحن
بنجهز اذا وصلتنا اي اشاره بدخول لسوريا
بحيث نكون جاهزين ولكن صعوبه الوصول الى
كل المناطق السوريه المتضرره يعني بان هذه
المساعدات قد لا تصل للجميع والجمعيه هنا
تقول انها لا تملك اليه لايصال المساعدات
لمناطق معينه وان هدفها انساني ويتمثل
بايصال المساعدات للمحتاجين في الشمال
السوري وجنوب تركيا راغده باهنام العربيه
برلين